there is number 21 zack grenke
wraps up this home stand wants to
give the astros a 7-1 home stand which
would be their second
best mark of a home stand of eight games
or more
for their best mark since 1989 and zach
on the year plumber
pretty solid no he's been amazing he's
also been highly entertaining to watch
with the antics that he does have out
there talking and working well with
martine maldonado
how about going back to the start of
last season until now he has a 2.90 era
but he's really rounded into form after
that first rough start of the season and
been
the true ace of this staff with justin
verlander on the il
owen two murphy
pops one towards the rockies dugout but
bregman has room and puts it away
zach grenkey strands two after two base
hits
well and antonio centella 3-0 391
18 strikeouts and that's where he's
improved from last year this year
much better strikeout to her nine-inning
ratio
so here's bregman
and another ground ball nolan spinning
throw-in
in time mcmahon with the 6-3 frame good
reach
great start for sensatella three ground
balls
so here's nolan aronado with that base
hit blackman up to 438.
the gold glover grenkey trying to start
a double play against the other gold
glover and he does
the six-time consecutive gold glover
starts a double play on the seven-time
consecutive gold glover
the astros get two outs quickly with
alex bregman coming up here
seeing the ball well he's just been
consistent but the active
streak that he has going of reaching
base you know he's reached every game
this year which is 22 but the 38
straight going back to 2019.
that is pretty impressive of course it's
the lead in the majors right there
fourth longest streak
and to start the season in astros
history and i can tell you this
he's likely not satisfied with what he's
doing
and only wants to be better but it's
only a matter of time before we see this
guy go off right
that fall into left field there you go
julia mentions the on base streak and
alex bregman continues it
he has now been on base every game this
year and going back to last year
bregman now 39 in a row three shy of his
career record
covering up garrett hampson hampton one
for two today
trying to bunt julie's on it quickly and
zach fly into the bag and he beats the
diving
garrett hampson for out number two that
is a great job by zach getting to the
bag in a hurry
senzitella will face the cleanup man
julie guriel
he's one for two and now he is
oh that's uh he's one for three now yeah
he's one for three
off the bat i thought he had whistled
that in front of
well here great catch by toppy that ball
was hit hard that's probably the hardest
hit ball all day yeah coming off the bat
you're right you're thinking well it's
going to be a sinking line drive instead
it was a rising line drive toby has to
go back and leap and catch good timing
right now tapia will leave things off
chop towards bregman on two hops tapia
heads down the line and he's a step late
as bregman makes the throw
on the move three ground outs from tapia
today went away here in the eighth
ryan mcmahon the batter with a 1-0 count
strike three called outside corner
grenkey with seven strikeouts again
back-to-back starts sam hilliard is
struck out and grounded out
slow curve and what a masterpiece from
zach grenke today
eight innings of three hit shutout
baseball
he retires the last 14. new pitcher is
agnoli paredes for the astros
called third strike and noli paradis
freezes tony walters that's a strikeout
to start his outing
beautiful slider now pitching in the
ninth inning of a scoreless game
oh yeah do it and nollie cannoli
he breaks over another slider for
another called strike
he's looked impressive here the first
two batters
two called third strikes in this inning
and now facing trevor story the hottest
hitter
in this rockies lineup ground ball
towards third
agnoli paredes with a one two three
ninth inning
the astros will try and walk it off in
the bottom half for the second time
in this home stand two outs nobody on
bregman at the plate
singled in the fourth couple of
groundouts to the left side
and this should be the out that takes us
for the first time
this year to extra innings and the old
california
tiebreaker first things first see if
rymel can come through
put together good at bats of late
and this ball of bullet up the middle
base hit tapia comes through
burfield go to third story makes it one
nothing colorado how about rybal
tapia so now the tying run 90 feet away
and
the winning run on first base for kyle
tucker who was
walked off the game just two days ago
last afternoon contest here at mid-may
park with a home run to right
tucker sends one into center field
lining it up
is hillyard bregman is tagging bregman's
going to come home here comes the throw
by hilliard and alex is safe with the
head first line we are tied at one
on a sacrifice fly by kyle tucker there
you see it the five-man infield
three on the left side two on the right
for miles straw
looking for something he can drive to
the outfield
line drive base hit miles strong wins
the game the astros walk it off
2-1 they complete a 7-1
home stand the astros sweep the rockies
of the two games here in houston and
mile straw gets the bathroom yuli
[Music]